The second episode of the final season of
Game of Thrones was a tense, character driven
exploration of the moments building up to
the arrival of the Night King's army of the
dead and the impending Battle of Winterfell.
Between a love scene that took viewers by
complete surprise, a sorrowful song sung around
the fire, a knighting that should have happened
ages ago, and Jon Snow dropping the bombshell
of all bombshells, fans are still buzzing.
But the thing that has people really talking
is the plan to protect the castle's most vulnerable
residents by hiding them in the crypt below
the castle.
"I'm going to be in the crypt with my son.
And I'd feel a lot better with you down there
to protect us."
"Alright.
I'll defend the crypt then."
On first blush, it seems to make perfect sense.
There's no area more secure in Winterfell
than the crypts, after all.
There are only a couple entry points, and
any invading army would need to fight their
way through the castle's formidable defenses
- and defenders - to reach it.
There's one major problem, though: this isn't
just any army.
It's the army of the dead.
Led by a guy whose source of power is the
ability to raise the dead and control them.
And guess what the crypt is filled with?
Uh-oh.
Naturally, fans are freaking out about this
seemingly obvious flaw in Jon's plan.
One fan wrote on Twitter, "Everyone's going
to hide in the crypt with all the dead Starks
while an army who can raise the dead approaches
and no one forsees a problem with that?"
And another tweeted,
"They keep mentioning how safe the crypt is
going to be.
After years of watching this show, I'm sure
that means the opposite."
Of course, this was hinted at in the promo
clips for the final season, as the first teaser
was called "The Crypts of Winterfell," and
it showed the icy grip of death coming for
our characters in the crypts.
And the episode three tease also hints at
this with clips such as Arya Stark fleeing
an unseen foe inside the castle, not to mention
this foreboding line from Daenerys:
"The dead are already here."
Perhaps most chilling is the fact that there
could be some familiar faces among the Night
King's new minions.
After all, this is the Stark family crypt,
meaning Jon's mom Lyanna is among those who
could rise, as is Rickon, who died in the
Battle of the Bastards.
And could we even see a headless Ned zombie?
The mind shudders at the thought.
"Your husband was an honorable man.
He should rest beside his family in the crypts
beneath Winterfell."
Though this horrifying theory may be a surprise
to fans of the show, it's no surprise to fans
of the books.
In fact, this scene was seemingly foreshadowed
way back in the very first of George R.R.
Martin's “A Song of Ice and Fire” novels,
where Jon Snow has a recurring nightmare about
this exact thing happening:
"Last night he had dreamt the Winterfell dream
again.
He was wandering the empty castle, searching
for his father, descending into the crypts…
When he turned he saw that the vaults were
opening, one after the other.
As the dead kings came stumbling from their
cold black graves..."
Of course, this being Game of Thrones, there's
really no way of knowing what will happen,
or who will live or die.
If luck is on the side of the living, perhaps
Arya will use her specially made dragonglass-outfitted
spear to slay wights and White Walkers galore,
and the little girl who swore to defend the
crypt will keep her promise.
With fan favorites like Tyrion set to be in
the crypts, though, fans are worried that
their worst fears will come to pass - and
we may even see some of our most beloved characters
then rise from the dead to fight for the Night
King.
All we know for sure is that not everyone
will survive the next episode of Game of Thrones
- and if this show gets any more tense, we
might not survive watching it ether.
"The things we do for love."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.